whew that seat was hot today the
nation's top health officials under
intense microscope today dr anthony
fauci cdc director rochelle walinski
both testifying before the senate health
committee on the federal covid response
and why the public should continue to
trust our major institutions and those
two
despite poor communication mixed
messaging seemingly inconsistent public
health guidance the list is long
here's senator patty murray questioning
wilinsky on the cdc abruptly changing
its isolation recommendations
i appreciate the background but i just
want to know straightforward if someone
is exposed to or has coven 19 and
they're vaccinated what do they do if
they are exposed to covet 19 and they
are completely boosted they should they
do not need to stay home um but they
should get a test at day five what about
unvaccinated same for unvaccinated for
isolation so isolation being those who
have had disease
what
i mean is it me
emily
the same thing i mean okay
yeah exactly harrison i thought you know
there was an incredible um
so many tense moments frankly especially
between dr fauci and
senator rand paul i thought there was a
lot of finger-pointing going on a lot of
accusations of stoking criticism in the
media that led to unhealthy discussions
about policy attacks on a personal level
rather than discussing the policies
truth and these officials accountability
for such harris
well and all of that aside i want to go
back to though what she just said kaylee
i mean you're talking to millions of
people now not just the room right no
the room that's fine but the bigger room
is out here all the peeps
that didn't make any sense was that
useful what she said and and isn't
testing the thing don't we want to
understand
yeah absolutely and we were promised
testing but not given it because the
biden administration dropped the ball
there's so much i think you hit on a
really important point harris so much
mixed messaging
the cdc guidelines a great example
reducing the isolation time and then
saying but you don't need to test at the
end even if you might still have viral
load that you're spewing to infect
others and then getting severe pushback
getting viral internet memes over your
cdc guidance having the cdc director
admitting it wasn't all based on science
only to then come back and revise the
guidelines to say oh well if you can
find a test yeah you should probably
test after five days we are at a really
really dangerous point in this country
when axios a few days ago had an article
uh called the biden administration's
credibility crisis and it was saying
look half the country doesn't have faith
in president biden i'm paraphrasing here
but when you stop trusting public health
officials that's when we have a problem
and we've gotten to that point when
they're still using the term the
pandemic of the unvaccinated one example
of many there is so such lack of faith
in the messengers coming out of this
white house we need new faces and we
need credible faces well and you know
that i lean hard on well who are these
unvaccinated people and if you want to
make it about politics then you're not
seeing all of the blacks hispanics and
others who for many reasons that dr
siegel and i went into last hour
don't trust the government don't trust
the vaccine
i mean how come the government doesn't
talk about them and and shoring them up
since they're identifying them as people
who need more in first treatment
carly there was a moment
in all of that
when this morning when dr fauci was
asked about treatments and he did talk
about you know some of them although
there are a lot of questions about why
we don't see them readily available to
doctors and when you do ask for plaques
for example um you're asked what the
race of the patient is that's an aside
but when fauci was asked about
treatments he talked about awards take a
watch
what's the current status of nih
research to better understand long covid
to look at
symptoms and potential treatments there
have been a number of awards that have
been given
most recently in september there was an
additional 470 million dollar funding
supported through the american rescue
plan
engaging about 100 researchers from 30
institutions
i asked our team to pull that out
because it just felt like a huge pivot
carl yes because it was and the um biden
administration and the health officials
dr rochelle wilinski and dr fauci they
always pivot
to talking about vaccines and away from
treatments and
that's a really big problem
it was huge news when
everybody found out that the biden
administration was prioritizing
us
giving
covet treatments to people based on race
obviously racist you need to treat
people based on their condition and not
on the color of their skin but the other
issue with that is that we shouldn't be
rationing treatment at all i mean with
this country should have enough
treatment you should have prioritized
that without a doubt and it is a failing
on the biden administration to to not
have that at this point operation warp
speed for treatments needs to happen
yeah i i don't know juan i to my mind
was just blown when he pivoted to
award-winning performances by himself
and others you've got to be joking me it
is not time for a victory lap it's time
to save some people's lives if they can
do it
i agree i think this the messaging has
been muddled especially on this latest
episode about how long to quarantine and
whether or not you need a test i don't
think there's any question that they are
dealing with an evolving problem here i
mean we have once in a generational
challenge in terms of this you know
pandemic but they've got to be clearer
now there's no argument though about the
success and the efficacy of vaccination
and the booster everybody agrees our
hospital system would not be strained
overloaded you know like a quarter of
the hospitals in the country at max
capacity right now and people having to
cancel
surgeries for cancer and other illnesses
if people were vaccinated i mean it's a
simple thing and i don't think we can
argue about cdc messaging but there's
been no questioning about that or about
the use of masks and remember you this
goes back this is nonpartisan this goes
back to
i hear all of what you're saying
but you know what you're really saying
here you're saying that this current
administration has come up with nothing
to help us go forward since president
trump's
operation warp speeds vaccines
that's what that drills down to and if
you want to say it differently if you
want to change the facts on that you've
got to call the white house and tell
them to do something better
build back better in the category of
covenant we got to get the facts the
facts
the facts stand pretty clear but you
know what we have vaccinations today uh
and we have testing available and that's
the key thanks to trump
oh my goodness and you really think that
biden came up with those vaccines please
say it before we go to commercials so
you don't get tweeted by the
distribution quadrants of the universe
the distribution has been under
president biden and he has made it
available and we have gotten i think
it's now he's convinced people not to
take it to the point where black
communities are suffering for that so he
wants to make up the difference on the
back end by prioritizing their care we
could go on but we only have an hour
a pulitzer prize well you have subsets
of people who are not vaccinated and you
have to help all of us all right okay
we're in it together i hear you i'm
committed to get to this commercial